oh ouais, allez, combattez-les confortablement,
pas la configuration chérie, ouais, est-
ce que vous m'avez demandé maintenant, j'ai
juste besoin de conclure le triple blocage et
tous ces hochets, c'est que vous nous le
montrerons prêt 10h15 chose que vous devriez
avoir comme un génial  fête ou quelque chose comme ça
mais je ne travaille pas à une fête
Je vais vous acheter une nouvelle robe et nous allons
vous coiffer et vous maquiller les couleurs Je
vais le porter quelque chose de cool monsieur où
sommes-nous
je pense que 15 ans va  tue l'aube d'
une nouvelle ère
tu n'as aucune idée gee pauvre plug je pense
que seule la vieille machine tu n'es pas prêt pour
cet endroit autour de tout peut arriver
rempli de créatures mystiques et
bourré de trésors indicibles
bien ne peut pas verrouiller le Vatican
[Musique]
tu